thank you for joining us America in the
lobby of Ramsey solutions BJ is with us
from Dayton Ohio hi BJ how are you hey
Dave I'm doing great thanks for having
us absolutely how can I help today I'm
trying to figure out if we should gift
our son a house for a wedding gift it's
just a modest 2-bedroom 1-bath or
three-bedroom one-bath house and the 35
to 45 thousand dollar price range Wow
very nice very nice
in Louisville wedding gift or in
Louisville wedding yeah your son okay so
is the bride's parents providing a
wedding no they are not there they have
say they're in the process of saving
$3,000 they have a very tight budget for
their wedding and they will be
graduating from college in December of
this year and we are in baby step 7 oh
yeah okay what what do the kids want
they think it might be a little too
generous but Mike what my concern is is
after reading Tom Stanley's millionaire
does next door about serve us serving it
on a silver platter mm-hmm oh no no that
that has to do with the kid that doesn't
have to do with the size of the gift
okay um the kid has ruined long before
the gift hits if the if the gift runs
the kid the kid was already not there no
the kid managed to save up almost a
hundred thousand dollars for college at
a private university through
scholarships through scholarships well
and and then what she like I mean in
that regard she is even more of a saver
than he is okay and they're so they're
responsible and then from an entitlement
mentality they neither want to have that
know this right they don't have trust
fund baby syndrome
no okay and so the this that giving them
what you could give them a $500,000
house it's not gonna ruin them okay
that's not that's not what Tom Stanley
talked about though in in that book is
when we started my was economic
codependence I was the phrase he used if
you remember yeah I do remember that and
so it's just codependence is what
amounts to okay just as reflected in
economics and so on now one of our goals
in
and not this current version of
Financial Peace University but we used
to talk about all the time is to make
sure that I'm the last Ramsey that ever
has a debt right overly conned and we're
hoping we're the last bowling without
any debt yeah
and in order to do that you have to pass
the you know otherwise they're gonna
have a mortgage correct and you can keep
them from having a mortgage now the
reason I asked what the kids wanted was
they they might rather have a wedding
and some help getting the first house
the no wedding in lieu of this house
well my son wants no wedding at all
that's that it is a man and the bride
would like he would get married in a
culvert yes he would he's a man you know
yeah he went I mean there's very few men
go I want a really large wedding I mean
that just seldom comes up you know no
but I mean they getting we get sucked
into them but you know I both of my
girls when they got married I they had
big weddings but the end but I gave them
a budget and they could spend that on
whatever they want it that neither guy
could neither guy had a chance I mean
they had watch the father of the bride
and so we spent every dime on the
wedding and that wasn't a bad thing it
was full right but they had the option
of putting the difference in cash in
their pocket and they didn't
in either case so I might have a little
girl talk with her okay and not let your
son being such a responsible tightwad
he's too much like me do it yeah I was
gonna say I wasn't gonna say it but
don't say it and because you know you're
very very smart and you're very careful
with math you always have been since
I've known you and I just I want to
leave some room for romance in the
middle of all in the middle of all this
numbers crunching that you and me do
okay and I probably like your son I'm
not gonna choose the wedding but I you
know let's say let's say my son Daniel
were getting married in a situation I'd
want to be sure that that we in Ramsey
eyes this girl like kind of against her
will and you know make her make her get
a tattoo and join the cult you know kind
of thing and in order to get a free
house I want it to be
I want us to enjoy the money too okay as
well as accomplish the goals and you've
reached the point that you can do that
is my in your finances you don't have to
make choices so you could say okay we're
gonna we're gonna raise this wedding up
about five ten thousand more and maybe
do the house and or maybe we sell that
house and use that money when you get
ready to do your first house in a couple
of years or you know little different
plan maybe but are you doing a bad thing
absolutely not if they both are all yes
we want the house that's a cool way to
start we're debt-free I would have them
sign a pledge and says I never borrow
money they're gonna save up and when
they move up in house Oh trust me we
already made them do that okay all right
so they're already indoctrinated
thoroughly they are we've made her drink
the kool-aid well just just my only
advice is because I I'm it's almost like
me talking to me right here cuz you're
you you think a lot like I do is just um
just leave some room for the for life to
happen okay just a little bit of romance
in there a little bit of enjoy this
money and I don't know this girl but I
can see your son being no no wedding
I'll take I'll sure season an Iowa farm
girl yeah but every little girl played
Barbie and they left them down the aisle
just about it sometime and so I just
want to leave room for that I'm okay
either way if they both decide not to
it's okay I'm not saying she's a bad
person she has to do that but I just
want to make sure all of us don't gang
up on her accidentally okay okay that's
good
hey thanks for dropping in good to see
you thank you very much hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show and so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind